-The president spent the lead-up
to the second
and final presidential debate
whining about the moderator
and releasing
some deeply embarrassing footage
of his interview
with "60 Minutes."
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
With less than two weeks
until the election,
as the pandemic rages
out of control
and millions of Americans
suffer the pain of loss
and economic hardship, the
president of the United States
has apparently decided
to make his closing message,
"The TV lady
was very mean to me."
All week, he's been threatening
to release his own footage
of an interview
with "60 minutes"
set to air this Sunday, claiming
the interview would somehow
prove that the media is unfair
to him.
Well, today, he finally did it,
and it's genuinely
one of the most embarrassing,
cringe-inducing things
I've ever seen on video,
and I'm including the time
that dude
tried to jump into
a frozen pool.
-Waaaah!
[ Groans ]
Basically, what Trump did today
was the equivalent
of posting that video
then claiming the pool
was biased against him.
[ As Trump ]
You heard I was coming.
I said, "Waaaah!"
[ Normal voice ] For example,
according to the footage
released by the White House,
"60 Minutes" correspondent
Lesley Stahl
asked Trump if he was ready
for tough questions,
and Trump immediately
started whining.
-You're gonna be fair.
-Just be fair.
-Eh, no,
I'm not looking for that.
I'm looking for fairness.
That's all.
Okay.
No, I'm not.
Well, I'm gonna be fair, you
don't ask Biden tough questions.
-Me?
-Huh?
It's terrible. It's terrible.
-Sorry, that's your big gotcha,
that video?
You couldn't handle
that rhetorical question?
It's like a boxing ref asking
if you're ready
for a good, clean fight
and responding,
[ As Trump ]
"No, I'm gonna bite his ear
because I'm bad at boxing."
[ Normal voice ] What Trump
was apparently pissed about
was the fact that Stahl
had the temerity to ask him
simple follow-up questions
about his brazen lies.
For example, Trump and the GOP
have gone out of their way
recently to claim they
don't want the Supreme Court
to overturn Obamacare
and its protections
for pre-existing conditions,
which is absurd,
since they're the ones
who brought the lawsuit.
Then, in the "60 Minutes"
interview, Trump admitted
he did want the court
to strike down Obamacare.
And when Stahl asked him how
he'd protect people with
pre-existing conditions,
Trump had no answer,
even though he's had four years
to come up with one.
-We'll have to see what happens.
It's got a ways to go.
I mean, we'll see what happens.
I think it will end --
I think -- I hope
that they end it.
It will be so good
if they end it.
-Are protected.
Will be totally protected.
They'll be protected, Lesley.
I mean, the people
with pre-existing conditions
are going to be protected.
As they are now.
-[ As Trump ] [ Stammering ]
[ Stammering ]
It's very simple, Lesley.
Everyone's gonna get a little
plastic baggy in the mail
with some loose
hydroxychloroquine
and a half-eaten stick
of Halls cough drops.
[ Normal voice ]
He obviously has no plan
and he has no intention
of coming up with one either,
because he doesn't care
what happens to people
with pre-existing conditions.
And by the way,
there are about
8 million more people
with pre-existing conditions now
that Trump let coronavirus
rage out of control.
He doesn't have a plan
to protect people
with pre-existing conditions.
He has a plan to give people
pre-existing conditions.
If he gets reelected,
he'll probably announce
a new coronavirus plan called
the "everyone Drink Out of the
Same Giant Cup Initiative 2020."
Then later in the interview,
Stahl asked Trump if he wanted
to lock up the Governor
of Michigan, Gretchen Whitmer,
as well the Bidens
and President Obama,
and Trump pretended to be aghast
at that question
as though it were absurd.
-When did I say lock her up?
I never said that.
-The Bidens,
you want to lock up Obama.
-Wait a minute.
When did I say lock her up?
When did I say lock up
the governor?
I didn't say lock up
the governor.
-All right.
-I never said it, Lesley.
I never said lock up
the governor.
Lesley, it's such a vicious
thing you just said.
I never said lock up
the governor of Michigan.
I would never say that.
-Yeah, you did. For one thing,
you basically called for
everyone to be locked up.
You're like a guy who gets
thrown out of the strip club
for eating out of the buffet
with your bare hands.
"Hey, sir, you can't just fill
your pockets with shrimp."
[ As Trump ] How dare you throw
me out! I'm a paying customer!
If anyone should be locked up,
it's you!
It's everyone here!
It's you, Destiny!
That champagne was flat!
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
You're not the only one
who knows how to film
things, you know?
We have cameras, too,
and they have recorded
you saying stuff,
stuff like this.
-These people
should be indicted.
This was the greatest
political crime
in the history of our country.
And that includes Obama
and it includes Biden.
Now you've got to get
your governor
to open up your state, okay?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Chuckling ] Lock her up.
Lock 'em all up.
-He's like Robert Durst
except if instead
of accidentally confessing
in a bathroom in private,
he does it at a rally in public.
[ As Trump ]
What the hell did I say?
Lock 'em all up, of course.
Is this thing on?
Are you people real?
Is this a rally?
[ Normal voice ] In fact,
it's become very clear that
as he lags in the polls,
Trump desperately wants
to re-create the 2016 election
by manufacturing
a bogus criminal investigation
of his opponent.
He's repeatedly called
for the Bidens to be prosecuted
and thrown in jail
by fabricating some BS
about the Biden family.
-That Biden family, and others,
but that Biden family
is corrupt.
It's a corrupt family.
[ Crowd chanting
"Lock them up" ]
And with me and my kids,
let me tell you, my kids --
I'll tell you something, though.
[ Chuckling ] "Lock 'em up."
You should lock them up.
Lock up the Bidens.
Lock up Hillary.
It's a criminal enterprise.
He's like a vacuum cleaner.
The father goes through and the
son comes in a vacuum cleaner.
Millions of dollars pouring in.
-What?
He's like a vacuum cleaner?
What are you talking about?
The only explanation
for this terrible analogy
is that Trump was looking
around the room
and just saw a vacuum cleaner.
"And who's your source for this
information, Mr. President?"
[ As Trump ] His name
is George -- George Glass?
[ Normal voice ]
Also, you don't get to
call anyone else a vacuum
cleaner when you're the one
who sucks in air like
a Dirt Devil.
Whenever you give a speech,
you sound like a Roomba
with a bad coke habit.
-[ Inhaling sharply ]
Trump knows that
then-FBI director James Comey's
last-minute announcement
about Hillary's e-mails
just 11 days before
the 2016 election
helped tank her campaign
and he's trying to fabricate
a similar situation
this time around.
Trump has been very explicit
about the fact
that he's trying to bully his
FBI director, Christopher Wray,
and his attorney general,
Bill Barr, to deliver
an October surprise for him
by opening a bogus investigation
of the Bidens
before the election.
-Let me ask you, Mr. President,
address Christopher Wray.
Will you replace him
in a second term?
-Well, I don't want
to say that yet.
He's been disappointing.
-Will you be appointing
a special prosecutor?
-We've got to get
the Attorney General to act.
He's got to act.
And he's got to act fast.
He's got to appointment
somebody.
This is major corruption,
and this has to be known about
before the election.
-Man, they're really just
trying to run the same play
from 2016 all over again.
It's like the Jets bringing
Joe Namath out of retirement
to be their QB in 2020.
Although, I guess
it couldn't get much worse.
"How are the knees,
'Broadway' Joe?"
"I had 'em taken out!"
Trump's like a guy who uses
the same pickup line
on every woman he meets because
it worked once back in 1990.
"Excuse me,
has anyone ever told you,
you look like current
supermodel, Kathy Ireland?"
And now we know from bombshell
new reporting
in "The Washington Post" last
night that Trump and his aides
have been pressuring both Wray
and Barr to announce
an investigation into the Bidens
before the election,
and threatening to fire
both of them if they refuse.
-"The Washington Post" reports
President Trump is considering
firing FBI Christopher Wray
after the election.
Mr. Trump is reportedly
frustrated that Wray
and Attorney General
William Barr have not done
what he hoped.
That included not saying
that Democratic presidential
candidate Joe Biden,
his son Hunter,
or other Biden associates
are under investigation.
-Trump's like that friend in
the group who still wears
a leather bracelet
and wants to get high,
and everybody else is like,
"Dude, we have kids now."
[ As Trump ] $7 Keystone buckets
at O'Hallihan's. Bring Tyler.
[ Normal voice ] You know,
it's bad when even Bill Barr
isn't going along
with your corrupt scheme.
Dude has played a central role
in decades
of right-wing cover-ups
from Iran-Contra
to the Mueller report
and was personally involved
in the decision to tear gas
peaceful protesters
in Lafayette Park.
This is like if Darth Vader had
refused to blow up Alderaan.
"We promised we wouldn't!
A Sith's only as good as his
word, guys."
Oh, was my helmet not on?
[ Chuckles ]
Is that why I didn't do
the classic voice?
[ Laughter ]
Also, how many times is Trump
gonna fire an FBI director
and Attorney General
after pressuring them
to do something corrupt?
He already did this to Comey
and Jeff Sessions,
who, by the way, is also
a monstrous [bleep]
If Bill Barr and the guy behind
child separation
aren't corrupt enough for you,
you need to do some
soul-searching.
Maybe Trump should post on that
Reddit forum,
"Am I the ass[bleep]?"
Of course, it won't surprise you
to learn that Trump
can't even explain what crime
he thinks Biden supposedly
committed.
You might remember earlier
this year when Trump
started using the term
"Obamagate" to describe
a mysterious crime that
supposedly involved
Barack Obama, Biden,
and Clinton.
Today, in the "60 Minutes"
interview, he complained again
that Stahl wasn't covering
Obamagate,
but when he was asked to explain
what Obamagate was
a few months ago, he could not.
-Mr. President in one of
your Mother's Day tweets,
you appear to accuse
President Obama
of the biggest political crime
in American history by far.
-Yeah.
-Those were your words.
What crime exactly are you
accusing President Obama
of committing, and do you
believe the Justice Department
should prosecute him?
-Obamagate.
it's been going on
for a long time.
It's been going on from
before I even got elected.
And it's a disgrace
that it happened.
And if you look at what's
gone on, and if you look at,
now, all of this information
that's being released,
and from what i understand,
that's only the beginning.
Some terrible things happened,
and it should never be allowed
to happen in our country again.
And you'll be seeing what's
going on over the next --
over the coming weeks,
and I wish you'd write
honestly about it, but,
unfortunately,
you choose not to do so.
Yeah, John, please.
-What is the crime exactly
that you're accusing him of?
-You know what the crime is.
The crime is very obvious
to everybody.
All you have to do is read
the newspapers, except yours.
-My God, man, at least do
some research before you lie.
Do a Google search for federal
crimes and just pick one.
"Mr. President,
what's Obamagate?"
[ As Trump ] Well,
he illegally imported
certain agricultural products
without properly declaring them
after a trip abroad.
That's bad.
Class B misdemeanor
with a possible sentence.
Hold on -- Four months in jail
and a $10,000 fine.
So checkmate, libs.
[ Normal voice ] Trump's insane
demand that Biden be prosecuted
is based on a flimsy report
about Hunter Biden
in "The New York Post" that even
"The Post"'s own reporters
refused to put their names on.
The whole thing
is the brainchild
of Italian Wile E. Coyote
Rudy Giuliani,
the same guy
who we found out yesterday
got duped by Borat.
-President Trump's personal
lawyer, Rudy Giuliani,
is denying he did anything wrong
in the new Borat movie.
His denial comes after word
of a compromising
and edited scene in the movie in
which Giuliani talks to a young,
fake female reporter
in a bedroom.
Giuliani says
he was adjusting his clothes
after taking off a microphone.
-I will say if Rudy
hadn't been tricked
by a Sacha Baron Cohen
character,
I would have assumed he was
a Sacha Baron Cohen character.
I mean, he looks like a guy
who either wears no makeup
or seven hours of makeup.
I mean, that's either
a weird old dude
or a teenager working real hard
to buy beer.
Of course, this isn't the best
prank ever pulled on Rudy.
The best prank is definitely
still the time
he looked at his wife and said,
"You're my cousin?!"
[ Laughter ]
Now, Rudy claims he was just
tucking in his shirt.
And honestly, who knows?
Maybe he was.
He's one of those weird old guys
who does stuff like
lie in on a bed
to tuck a shirt in
or keep half a tuna salad
sandwich
wrapped in a newspaper
in his briefcase.
I'm sure his super has had to
come up to his apartment
to pull cigar butts
out of his shower drain.
So that's the guy.
That's the guy right there,
asking us to believe Joe Biden
is somehow a criminal.
The reason they have to
go to these absurd lengths
is simple --
Nothing else is working.
For example, tonight
was the second and final
presidential debate. Now we
taped this in the afternoon,
so I have no idea how it went.
But I'm willing to guess
it wasn't a home run for Trump
considering that his performance
at the last debate was so bad
the Debate Commission had
to add a rule allowing them
to mute the candidates' mics.
I'm guessing Trump made a lot
of faces and flapped his arms
around like I do when I can't
get the Wi-Fi to connect.
Or he ran over to Biden's mic
and did the whole debate
Springsteen
and Little Steven style.
I will make one prediction
in the hours
before the mute button debate --
It won't work.
I get that you had to try
something,
but Donald Trump
will still be there.
You could be the best ballroom
dancer in the world,
but if your partner is a moose
on roller skates,
it's not going to work.
Personally, I think they should
have just put Trump
in a soundproof Plexiglass
booth.
He'd just be standing there
screaming for 90 minutes
like a contestant
on a Japanese game show.
Or better yet, make it
one of those money booths.
Judging from his tax returns,
he needs the cash.
"Mr. President, this question is
for you."
[ As Trump ] Quiet, quiet!
I thought I saw a $20 in there!
[ Normal voice ] I'm also
willing to predict Trump
didn't knock it out of the park
at the debate.
For one thing, when he was asked
earlier this week
what he was doing to prepare,
he basically said he wasn't.
-What am I doing to prepare?
I'm doing this.
I've done very well in debates,
and you do what you do.
You just do what you do.
-You just do what you do.
I think I saw that
on a river rock at Target.
Trump spent less time prepping
and more time whining about
the moderator,
NBC's Kristen Welker,
and generally speaking,
if you're spending all your time
in the lead-up to the debate
complaining about the moderator,
probably means you're not
expecting a great performance.
And yet that's exactly what
Trump and his allies on Fox
were doing -- whining that
Welker was some sort of
secret liberal out to get him.
-The fact that Kristen Welker
is, you know,
a dyed-in-the wool, radical-left
Democrat or whatever she is.
I've known her for a long time.
She's extraordinarily unfair.
-And this moderator, whose
parents are Democratic donators,
who was a registered Democrat
before,
who has the most hostile
questions possible
to Kayleigh McEnany,
whoever the press secretary is,
and the president, how does she
get picked to be the moderator
at this debate?
It's incredible.
-Donaters? I'm pretty sure
the word is "donors."
"I'm an organ donator.
I'm trying to give my brain
away, but they won't take it."
[ Laughter ]
This is all such phony outrage.
You guys weren't even happy
when someone
from your own network
moderated the debate.
The only way these petulant
babies would have been satisfied
is if Trump was allowed to talk
to a mirror for 90 minutes
and then we get
three whole news cycles
about how unfair the mirror was.
"That was one of those mirrors
they put in gyms
to make you feel fat
so you keep coming back!
It wasn't his fault!
The president's been very clear
that he wants to prosecute
and imprison
his political opponents
in order to stay in power.
He's actively trying
to make it happen right now
by bullying law enforcement
officials and manufacturing
a smear campaign against
the Bidens.
He's looking for dirt wherever
he can find it.
I guess you could say...
-He's like a vacuum cleaner.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
-God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask. We love you.